Pour ne louper aucune vidéo
abonnez-vouset activer la petite cloche.
Salut les Épicurieuse et les Épicurieux.
Je ne sais pas
où vous en êtes dans votre journée,
si c'est le lever ou le coucher
mais si vous êtes aupetit déjeuner,
vous êtes peut-être en train
de déguster un délicieux croissant.
Trempédans le chocolat ou
un café au lait, j'adore.
C'est une jolie pâtisserie,
qui, n'ayons pas peurdes mots,
symbolise un peu l'art
de vivre à la française.
La recette de ce croissant au beurre
avec de la pâte feuilletée
a d'ailleurs sans doute vu le jour
en France dans les années1920.
Mais bon, comme je n'ai aucune envie de
vous rouler dans la farine,
je dois vous avouer
qu'à l'origine le croissant
ou plutôt, les pâtisseries
en forme de croissant
n'ont pas vu
le jour dans l'hexagone.
Pour ceux qui aiment
les belles histoires autant que les croissants,
sachezque la légende situe
ses origines en 1683,
à Vienne, en Autriche, alors que les
ottomans assiègent laville.
Une nuit, ils décident d'entrer
dans la ville par un souterrain.
Mais des boulangers viennois,
déjàà l'œuvre, les repèrent,
donnent l'alerte et l'assaut est repoussé.
Pour commémorer l'événement, les
boulangers viennois inventent une pâtisserie
en forme de croissant reprenant
le symbole représentésur le drapeau ottoman.
Ça évidemment, c'est la légende.
Alors certes, le croissant est autrichien.
Le premier a, semble-t-il, été
commercialisé aux alentours de 1840.
Le "Kipferl".
Mais àl'époque, ils étaient
confectionné à partir d'une pâte briochée.
Son origine est sûrement
moins épique et encore plus lointaine.
Il y a plus de 2000 ans déjà, les perses, les assyriens,
les grecs et les premiers chrétiens
servaient les pâtisseries en forme
de croissant lors descérémonies religieuses.
Quoi qu'il en soit, je ne vais pas
me faire prier pour en croquerun
et le déguster religieusement.
Hmm, c'est bon !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisserun pouce bleus.
Merci les Épicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands, en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater abonnez-vous et activer la cloche.